we we don't have to wear that nothing  because we got the phone and we're  burning one hell of a something hey  they're gonna see some ad space  I'm really sorry I thought something  serious no it is like when I started the  human race human race where did you two  go giving more how did it father died a  surgeon typical patient and on a few  logistical patience but a third you  never have don't be scared okay see you  will be able to defeat it okay where she  wants to do her  [Music]  we're gonna let it go I don't understand  why I should have to pay the price my my  children should have to pay a price the  only thing I can think of that's close  to justice we can learn enough so they  can put it out out  you